yeah what we're in the dish we're in the
district then we're gonna find out what
the [ __ ] that really means because we
have no idea what state were in we're a
state of confusion that's for sure yep
we're a lyin Rudy you know us is food
Beast oh my god the steak just melts GQ
sent us across the country to find the
best cocktails food and bars around
you're watching where's the bar
oh [ __ ] we are in our nation's capital I
think yes that's I you know it we'll
check that later but for now it's good
this is the nation's capital arguably
the world's capital definitively the
capital of the United States of [ __ ]
America we're in front of a diplomat we
were sent here by a friend Morgan she's
the bartender and she promised us a dope
drink she promised a dope fish dish so
we're gonna go inside and eat and drink
and it would be my basis fish dish Oh
Morgan hello gentlemen what's up how are
you about to get better
we suited up for DC feel pretty
presidential right now you look
extremely presidential I believe Obama
actually owns that coat you feel
powerful I feel more powerful than when
I was in California I also feel like I
can just pay people to do whatever I
want yeah it doesn't quite work like
that you sure enough to wine and dine
them a little bit okay gotcha then you
have to put the ease into it yeah ease
into it and then we pay them and then
they do [ __ ] for us
not exactly but it's a good start that's
how politics works this is a beautiful
beautiful place it's been open for a
little over two years now so it's so
pretty new almost everything in the
building is an antique it's like built
out for presidents yeah I'm guessing
late diplomat it's mostly known for its
food but it's its cocktail program is
phenomenal it's sort of almost like a
hidden gem of a cocktail program because
people don't necessarily think about it
right and that way they see per capita
at one point was the largest consumer of
wine we're in the top three every year
but we are also in the top five
consumers of spirits
so DC loves to drink general who would
like I'd be like super stoked to see you
fightin comes in a fair amount so always
nice to see him as Clare come in here
from time to time you know Kevin Spacey
has come in a couple of times by the
brunch she's my favorite president yeah
tell me about the block cuz I mean like
you mentioned like this kind of champion
in the area
like here's what they dip lament well I
mean Logan Circle its newly renovated
and become a huge food scene it was more
considered a residential neighborhood
until 14th Street blew up with its
foodie restaurant district there's a lot
of great awesome history about this area
in general and then also an
up-and-coming food scene and DC is very
quickly establishing itself as a food
and cocktail City and when I found out
you were coming I wanted to make a drink
that sort of hit a lot of aspects of DC
so it is an apple and cherry and vanilla
infused Bombay Sapphire
I like doing a lot of infusions because
it's something that you can do a lot
with different flavors and it's pretty
easy so I went and picked apples myself
really a couple days ago yeah so I I
wanted some local flavors so I picked
them up in a farm in Maryland we are not
worth that wait for it okay we want
things to be fresh and local and
constantly changing and adapting the
name of the drink is a libation without
representation what's this one time back
to so this is time back to a French 75
so French 75 at its base is gin lemon
sugar and sparkling wine
champagne
and then instead of sugar simple syrup I
did honey again local honey this is in
fact urban district honey so which is
very difficult to define and then lemon
juice
so that is libation without
representation these are your tax
dollars at work
pretty much damn near oh that's
fantastic
I can taste like the drive out that you
had to make to get these apples you
seriously you could taste it all the
fruit really plays well with the gin you
know like all the botanicals like it
really does just accent it and kind of
bring it out it's a little sweet kind of
fruity a little tartness it's like a
poem of DC intricacies Cheers
to the President to Congress to the
Majority Whip I was impressive good job
no so we've had a great great cocktail
you've given us a little DC history but
what I've heard is uh you know the
chef's I've met him before okay
and I think you may heck us up you might
slight us into his diem real quick see
it's all about who you know let's go to
schmooze it up let's smooth it out all
right sweet shall we keep holding hands
Rudy Eli this is our chef de cuisine me
too hey that's the guy the diplomat just
give you a little background what our
philosophy of food is is kind of be like
we're eating in Paris right it's very
simple classic French bistro food so
today for you we're gonna present our
plot to jour on Thursdays we do the
Dover sole Meuniere we get this fresh
flown from off the coast of Holland make
it shipped over nine we have a guy pick
it up at the airport and deliver it to
us fresh it's a wonderful product and
people come around just to get it from
us we're gonna make a little score down
here at the end and kind of loosen up
some of the skin a little bit so this
will be our you know a presentation side
store it's gonna flip it over and do the
exact same thing so make sure if you're
gonna make like French bistro food at
home you have your tool box yeah how
many of these you go through a day we do
about 40 per night oh wow now we have
the basic skin so we're just gonna trim
it up with some scissors how does this
kind of kind of relate to DC you know
like what else do you guys do here it's
not all fine-dining everything very
close you know casual kind of upbeat
energy we're not setting standards of
what you have to wear how you have to be
when you're here you can just come in
and have a great time we're just gonna
season it with salt we're gonna judge it
Wonder flower so wonderful hours a
little bit finer grain flour and it's
gonna do a nice even coating we're just
going to use a little blended oil and
do it ah nice presentation yeah once
it's cooked we'll play it off the bone
and then build it all together back
light as a would you look like if it was
hole still oh but you're gonna play out
the bone for them yeah we'll put lay out
the bone so the guys have no bones and
they're you know they don't have to do
any work when they're eating oh so we
got a little color now so we're gonna go
ahead and put this in the oven so why
that's in the oven we're gonna start
making our brown butter sauce yeah and
our asparagus and then in this pan we're
gonna make we have a little chicken
dodged it's me reduced chicken stock
cream and a lot of butter
yeah we're just going to heat up our
asparagus in there so as you see the
butter starting to oh it's starting to
brown yeah starting to brown you add
anything to it to preferred to bread
like they know in the skillet
we have redness yet all the years that's
been in the milk solids are started they
start to brown we're gonna hit it with
some lemon juice and some capers
it was live in here finished it with
some parsley and some salt now we have
our fish that's already cooked so now we
got to take it off the bone we're gonna
run a spatula down the center of the
bone and start kind of just pushing the
fillet off the bone gotta be real gentle
cut how gentle the fish is you want to
hold its shape - yeah you want to hold
its shape so now we can just build it
back together let's go we got our
asparagus and then now we have our brown
butter sauce I love French people they
got this [ __ ] mania butter and that's it
so this is our Dover sole Meuniere from
the diplomat enjoy guys thank you thanks
all right let's see we got here
Oh crispy on the outside it's flaky on
the end it's not too hot which is
awesome the bar I just want to drink the
butter I just want to drink this all I
want to put it into smoothie
it's amazing chef you need you need an
immaculate amount of awards this is
insane
coming in ya gotta feed the people you
don't mean Jess get it yeah come dear
plain yep
oh just been in the French love all
around mm-hmm I'm just gonna go ahead
and say it if you're in DC club going
anywhere else come here we're done
that's the outro come to the bar grab a
drink maybe I don't think you can come
in the kitchen but you can probably sit
outside Morgan makes the drinks and
we'll make the food for it is fantastic
you see all three ready 1 2 3